my old business mentor um
and um i'm showing this to you because
it's significant for
the notion of culture
and
attracting the right people when it
comes to a business a lot of people
don't understand the importance of it
because humans are very very expensive
and i'll tell you why i don't hire
employees anymore
on businesses going forward i'll deal
with that separately but
this is so significant it made a huge
difference in the direction of my hiring
practices and
basically the systems that i put in
place to hire which i'll talk a little
bit more about in a second but i just
want you to watch this it's a quick
three minute clip i'm going to speed it
up a little bit uh the story behind it i
just kind of narrate over a little bit
but
this guy's dancing by himself at the
sasquatch music festival if you want to
look it up just search for
sasquatch music festival 2009 guy starts
dance party
and slowly but surely like one guy shows
up and then another random dude might
show up and you know there's no
coordination here there's nothing like
there's nothing to see this is not
you know
this is not anything that's going to
qualify for a music awards um you know
backup dancer trust me on that one it's
not like you're missing out on anything
anyway i'm going to speed it up a little
bit more so you can see what happens
here comes here comes big boy
he joins the uh he joins the dance party
i'm going to speed up two times speed
big boys dancing they're all flipping
around they're having a good time here
comes a couple more guys a few more guys
a few more guys
and then before you know it it's a
freaking swarm
okay everybody's just kind of running to
go and sort of dance with this guy now
at first glance you might look at this
and be like yeah shut up you don't know
what you're talking about but there's
again there's significance to what i'm
telling you here
this matters and this is only about
two-thirds of the way through the video
i mean this like continues throughout
the entire video you can go look it up
the reason why this is so significant is
when you get the right people on board
your first one or two employees
everything else really does take care of
itself it's like
it's like a snowball
you know you start it you pack it up and
you kind of put it in the ground you
kind of start to roll it it starts to
pick up size but it only picks up a
little bit of size at a time until it
gets really big and then it's gathering
a lot more snow it's always that bottom
piece in the snowman it gets super heavy
and you can't do anything with it
this is so important your first few
hires you have to get them right you
have to get the right people because if
you don't you'll never get a situation
like this ever to happen with the hyper
growth phase
nine out of ten businesses fail and
any business that relies on human
resources
needs to take a close look at the people
that they're going to invite into their
business you know some of the way that i
talk to you guys about be careful about
the kind of woman that you invite into
your life
and i think there's going to be a lot of
stuff in my next book on
making bank and entrepreneurship tips
but i talk a lot about you know a lot of
the personal unplugging that i had to do
in this book
and
um
you know inviting the right people in
your personal life is one part of the
equation you know the wrong woman can
really destroy it it's the same thing
with a business you invite the wrong
people into your business
it could be a disaster now the point
that i wanted to let me pull this out of
the screen here uh
the next point that i wanted to make
with hiring the right people is where to
get them
okay
the absolute best place is not
want ads you know your local classifieds
your linkedins your indeeds whatever
else is out there
most of those people are manipulative
time wasters just looking for a j-o-b so
they can pay a bill
the best talent that you're ever going
to find
you're going to have to poach from
another company they're already employed
somewhere else you're never going to get
the absolute best talent replying to a
wanad sitting at home on their butt
looking for their next job it's a fact
of life you can argue as much as you
want with it show me your results and
then we can talk i've got the results i
know how to hire the right people i'm
telling you exactly how this works
the best place you're going to get your
next best employee and this is if you
know even if you're a manager or a team
lead and you work in a company you're
looking for somebody you're going to
have to poach them from a competitor or
somebody that works in a similar field
let's talk about why i don't employ
people anymore so this is the second
point
um no it's not a mosh pit it it kind of
looked like a mosh pit but uh trust me
i've i've been in mosh pits i was a head
banger when i was a kid and there was
definitely a lot of moshing i did
um so why i don't employ people anymore
well human beings are expensive
and if i'm being honest
they're expensive inefficient
many times incompetent
um they cross they cause drama endless
drama
sick days fighting with people in the
office you got to move them from one
seat to another they're banging each
other there's all kinds of stuff that
goes on
um
it's my view that going forward and
one of the books that actually made a a
big difference in the lens in which i
viewed running business was a book
called company of one
uh you can get it off amazon i think i
listened to the audiobook uh it's not
that long
but it breaks down the uh the importance
and
the benefits more specifically to
not having a large office space brick
and mortars like desks and computers and
phone systems and security and all sort
of stuff
um you save a lot of aggravation running
a company of one so
if you want more insight on that i'm
just going to give you the resource i
don't need to talk about it that much
anymore but my experience running a
business and i've probably
hired and fired if i'm being honest um
running my own between running my own
businesses and what i did in my 20s in
the collection industry because i was a
regional manager
at least 100 people easily 125 people
like you know to kind of give you a
little bit of insight and if you guys
want to talk a little bit deeper on the
topic you know book me for a consult my
links are always below if you want to
hop on a one-on-one but
one of the things that we would do to
ensure that we had the right people on
board is i would offer them a bonus to
quit
so
the entire hiring process was basically
done with parties there's actually a
video on my youtube channel so if you
search on my youtube channels for
entrepreneurs and cars how i hire people
with parties you can go watch that video
it's from the very early days from like
2014 or 15
but the
offering of a bonus to have them quit
was so significant because you could get
rid of people that didn't want to be
there i could i could hire somebody and
i could talk to them usually after
training about week three and i'd pull
them in my office they wouldn't know
anything about this there was no there
was nothing given whatsoever yeah
actually that's where i got the idea
from zappos but i actually tweaked it a
little bit differently so
um i actually did a big tour of probably
about six or seven of the highest rated
most profitable
fastest growing companies with the best
office cultures and zappos was one of
them i've been to zappos like two or
three times i've hung out with tony shea
he's dead now i can't remember what
happened to him i think he committed
suicide or overdose on something about a
year or two ago um but you know strange
dude but you get the idea right so
the reason why you offer them the money
to quit is you get rid of somebody that
doesn't really want to be there because
if you say to them hey look you know
how's things going do you like the
office how are the people are you
treating you well you've been trained
properly
yeah yeah you know they you know they
seem interested then that's when i'll be
like well how about if i offer you a
thousand dollars to quit right now just
give you a thousand dollars you can go
home you never have to come back it's
just a bonus if you're not actually that
interested in being there and i would
even push it up sometimes fifteen
hundred seventeen fifty two thousand
dollars
um i pushed it up to twenty five hundred
bucks once because i really wanted to
see if this guy wanted to quit and he
ended up being one of my best sales
people in that particular office that i
had so um you know it's one of the
strategies that i've used and employed
it's it's very very successful it's one
of those things yeah did his house catch
fire yeah there's there's an article out
there somewhere sorry i'm bouncing back
and forth it's like squirrel you know so
entrepreneurs are we bounce around a lot
so that's why i don't employ people
anymore and that's how i would kind of
test them it's kind of a [ __ ] test you
know we talk about you know competency
tests in the sexual marketplace women do
it to to guys and i always tell you guys
you know i covered in quite a different
quite a few different parts of my book
about testing people
you know specifically women also
it's kind of a [ __ ] test do you really
want to be here if you don't here's two
thousand dollars you can take and [ __ ]
off and go home sort of thing right uh i
did have one guy take me up on it once
and i was more than happy to pay him the
bonus to get him out of there he went on
to create a very successful uh painting
business and um you know runs a couple
of different trucks as a entire crew he
likes doing it right like that was his
calling it wasn't working for me
on a sales team uh making calls on warm
leads he wanted to work with his hands
and paint walls so um it's a good thing
and you know moving people out of your
business into the right place it's it's
it's a it's a very
i mean i want to say noble thing to do
but you get the idea
you